méxico da un paso más en el camino de la
legalización de la marihuana la cámara
de diputados aprobó el proyecto para
regular el consumo el cultivo y el
comercio de marihuana con fines
recreativos en todo el país pero falta
que antes del 30 de abril el senado
ratifique los cambios que le hizo la
cámara y finalmente la firma del
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
si supera todos esos pasos méxico será
el tercer país del continente en
permitir el consumo recreativo de
marihuana en todo su territorio después
de uruguay y canadá
los diputados que defendieron la
propuesta aseguran que así se ayudará a
combatir la guerra contra el
narcotráfico
los índices de violencia y criminalidad
se han incrementado y se han perdido
numerosas vidas en un conflicto derivado
de la prohibición pero los opositores
rechazan esta idea
no resolverá el problema no hay
evidencia empírica pues el crimen
organizado seguirá trabajando con las
drogas que les aportan mayores
dividendos la legalización ahora depende
de lo que decida el senado aunque allí
ya se había aprobado la norma en
noviembre de 2020 hasta ahora el
proyecto permite que todos los adultos
puedan consumir marihuana solo que no
podrán hacerlo frente a menores de edad
ni en lugares donde esté prohibido fumar
también aumenta la cantidad de cannabis
que puede llevar una persona y cambia el
límite de 5 a 28 gramos que son unos 28
cigarrillos los mexicanos podrían
cultivar la planta dentro de su casa
comprarla en tiendas autorizadas para
vender marihuana o en las asociaciones
de cannabis que se podrán crear